what's your plan you may go the hell
away from me okay I'm sure you have good
reasons to bust that ear but I need to
get out of here - yeah not my problem
pitchblack
we need a light screw it I'll go first
oh you okay
[Music]
long
you have a problem I got a problem with
you I love you buddy he doing here she's
my daughter too
see what I said
[Music]
what's your plan it's my plan and I
decide what goes down
oh you got that yeah
come on my name is Joseph Aris and I'm
the writer director of a way out a way
out is a story-driven co-op game
it is designed played and experienced
only in split-screen co-op which means
you have to play the game with a friend
either online or on your couch the game
starts in a prison you play as Vincent L
do
UNEP friend will get to know your
characters and uphold their story
together you don't know anything about
me meant maybe not but Harvey kills
aren't very close to me with or without
you I'm going after let me show you some
of the scenarios in the game on the
right side you see Leo was already
imprisoned on the left you see Vincent
who just arrived now if you look to the
right again you can see that Leo can be
controlled while Vincent is in a
cutscene here is another one then
certainly you are now in the laundry
room your goal smuggle sheets using a
laundry cart and you can approach the
scenario in different ways either get
the cart with Vincent you know I got a
good pack right here I think it's got
your name on it
it's broken I don't know or with Leo's
can't over you idiot
yeah but I think those two guys are just
about to fight ah what up what drip in a
way out you will experience something
new all the time everything you do in
the game is unique for that scene we
want you and your friends to be focused
and engaged throughout the entire story
but let me tell you this is just the
beginning of what she was experiencing
in a way out
oh yeah
relax ma'am a doctor